the year is 1937 in Los Angeles an old
man named Hanan Fuller is seen writing a
letter for his closest Apprentice
Douglas Hall in the letter Fuller talks
about an unpleasant truth about the
world after finishing up he leaves the
letter with a trusted bartender named
Ashton and tells him to hand it over to
Douglas however right after Fuller
depart Ashton sneakily opens the letter
and reads it shocked by the contents he
then drives to a place he would never
usually go to after driving for hours
his car is the only car on the road it's
just him and the Heat and the dust there
are warnings and barricades that tell
him to stop but he doesn't listen when
Ashton reaches a bit further he realizes
that something isn't right there's no
movement no life as if the world around
him is crumbling slowly and when he gets
out of the car what sees him shocks him
to the core it appears to be the end of
the world all he can see is endless
lines of Matrix this is when Ashton
realizes that the world around him is
all fake and he himself is just an
artificial creation meanwhile the old
man from earlier Fuller returns home and
lies down next to his wife however when
he closes his eyes he wakes up in the
present-day Los Angeles of 1999. now
this is the real world it is then
revealed that the 1937 world is just a
virtual reality simulation and Fuller is
the creator of it this world gives
people a perfect experience of the past
they can interact with computerized
people make friends and even have fun
with girls damn and despite being a
simulated world the characters there are
oblivious but they are not real they are
electronic people living a normal human
life just like Ashton a person from The
Real World however can temporarily take
control of a character in The VR world
and do whatever they please with that
control in the next scene Fuller who has
just woken up from the virtual world
cautiously leaves the building he then
goes to a bar and uses the Payphone to
call Douglas but the call is not
answered soon a mysterious man appears
and Fuller follows him outside the two
chat for a while but shockingly the man
stabs Fuller with a knife and murders
him the next morning Douglas wakes up
and finds blood-stained clothes in his
laundry buckets he's obviously confused
where it came from but before he can
investigate he gets a call from
detective McBain of the LAPD and learns
about his mentor Fuller's murderer the
two then meet at Fuller's apartment here
it is revealed that Douglas had a close
relationship with Fuller and that they
were working on a highly classified
project which is the virtual reality
world of 1937. the detective mentions
that Douglas has become the prime
suspect of the murder as he was the last
person Fuller tried to contact before
his death just then the two encounter a
distraught young woman named Jane in
Fuller's bedroom when Douglas questions
her she reveals that she is the only
daughter of Mr Fuller and is only
returned from Paris after learning of
her dad's death she got back awfully
fast Douglas then leaves the two alone
for interrogation while he goes to the
VR lab there he talks with his co-worker
Jason Whitney and the latter reveals
that Fuller was secretly testing the
1937 La simulation Douglas is caught off
guard as he was under the impression
that the company was months away from
the first trial
afterwards Douglas returns home and goes
through his audio messages in one of
them an anxious Fuller tells him that he
has found something incredible and that
he has left a letter for him inside the
1937 VR simulation because he fears his
own death is imminent Douglas then heads
straight back to the VR lab and tells
his colleague Jason about the message he
asks him about the VR characters Fuller
interacted with last night and also
Reveals His desire to go into the VR
simulation Jason is naturally against
this however Douglas is adamant on
finding answers as now even the police
are starting to suspect him of being the
murderer moreover he himself is not sure
if he's innocent because all evidence
points to him and he can't even remember
what happened that night Jason finally
agrees to let him go into the system but
only for two hours shortly after the
preparation for the simulation commences
and after a few adjustments Douglas is
sent back to 1937 La Jason assigns him
the role of a wealthy Bank clerk named
Joan Ferguson at first Douglas who now
possesses Ferguson seems confused and
tries to process everything that just
just happened but soon he has taken
aback by the accurate representation of
the city which makes him smile for a
while then he takes a break from
Ferguson's work and goes to meet
Fuller's 1937 double named grierson who
is a historian the two talk for a while
but surprisingly grierson asserts that
he doesn't remember writing any letter
to him here it is revealed that once a
person leaves the simulation his or her
double will immediately forget about the
events that occurred while they were
under control but with that being said
grierson admits that he has a clue
probably because he remembers some
fragments of his memories this leads
Douglas to the bartender Jerry Ashton
surprisingly Ashton turns out to be the
1937 double of Jason which takes Douglas
by surprise however he ignores it and
inquires if Fuller left a message for
him the bartender feigns ignorance and
denies receiving any messages it seems
like he's bitter as he has now learned
the truth about being a simulation
hearing this Douglas is puzzled and he
suddenly begins to hallucinate he
quickly rushes to the bathroom suffering
from a seizure before collapsing on the
ground back in the 1997 VR lab warning
signs go off and Jason terminates the
connection and brings Douglas back Jason
explains that the unit started glitching
because Douglas spent two hours inside
the simulation which is double the
recommended time after collecting
himself Douglas shares his experience
inside the simulation and happily tells
Jason that the VR very much Works
meanwhile in the 1937 simulation Ashton
the bartender speaks with John Ferguson
once he emerges from the washroom
however Ferguson is puzzled how he got
to the hotel and doesn't recall having
any conversation with Ashton back in
1997 a waiter named Tom Jones from the
bar outside which Fuller was killed in
shows up at the company HQ he speaks
with Douglas privately and mentions that
he saw the crime taking place while the
latter asks about the killer Jones
reveals that it was none other than
Douglas himself he then demands a large
Ransom to keep his mouth shut about the
murder Douglas is naturally puzzled as
he doesn't recall killing his own Mentor
however suddenly something takes over
him as if if he has become possessed
Douglas then attacks Jones with
tremendous rage prompting him to run
away at this point he has become
extremely confused and doesn't know whom
to trust and whom not to later Douglas
takes Jane out for dinner and tells her
everything it's clear that the two have
started to like each other and Jane
advises him to walk away from all of
this before he gets hurt like her father
did Douglas thanks her for her concern
and soon the two start dancing one thing
leads to another and the two start
making out following the romantic dinner
Douglas returns home and later that
night several police officers storm into
his place and take him to the station on
suspicion of the murder of Tom Jones
detective McBain reveals that Jones came
to the police station and gave a
statement claiming he saw Fuller leaving
with Douglas on the night he was
murdered however Jones was brutally
murdered last night the damning evidence
is enough to keep Douglas behind bars
but the very next morning Jane arrives
at the station and bails him out she
even vouches for Douglas saying that he
was present with her during the time
Jones was killed Jane is sure that
Douglas is Innocent but he feels that it
just because he doesn't remember
anything doesn't mean he's not the
killer searching for answers Douglas
goes straight to the VR lab and
teleports his Consciousness into John
Ferguson's body in 1937 La he then goes
to meet grierson Fuller's VR double it's
late at night and the old man doesn't
want to talk but Douglas promises to
reveal why he sometimes wakes up in
unknown places if he comes with him
shortly after the two go to the Wilshire
Grand Hotel and grierson reveals that in
the last three days he's been having
strange memory flashes where he finds
himself at the hotel time and time again
hearing this Douglas becomes happy and
he pressures grierson to recall if he
gave someone a letter or a note after
much effort the old man finally
remembers giving a letter to Ashton the
bartender however before Douglas can
make his way to the counter Ashton runs
away Douglas chases him to the basement
and eventually confronts him
unfortunately Ashton pulls out a gun and
demands to know what's going on Douglas
pretends to know nothing but Ashton
tells him that he noticed Douglas
switching places with Ferguson he also
reveals that he read the letter left by
Fuller her Ashton knows that he is an
artificial creation and the world around
them is not real to see for himself
following the instructions on the letter
Ashton drove to a place he would never
go to otherwise to his shock after
reaching a certain point he found out
that there was no life it's simply a
computer simulation sounds like Ashton's
been getting into the bath salts Douglas
is puzzled as to why Fuller would write
to him about the limitations of
simulation because he already knows them
but before he can say anything Ashton
threatens to kill him for messing with
people's minds and tries drowning him in
a pool Douglas fights for his life and
in the VR lab his real self can also be
seen convulsing luckily Jason arrives in
the nick of time and brings his friend
back from the simulation Douglas is
shaken up by the incident and declares
the project a mistake he then announces
his decision to shut it all down much to
the dismay of Jason following this
Douglas goes to meet Jane at her hotel
but learns that she has already checked
out detective McBain who has also come
to meet Shane approaches Douglas and
reveals something shocking he claims
that according to his research Fuller
doesn't have a daughter and that there's
no woman named Jane Fuller in the U.S or
France after a while Douglas bribes the
hotel driver to obtain the last address
where he dropped the woman who claims to
be Jane Fuller there someone directs
Douglas to a woman named Natasha
Molinaro the cashier at a supermarket in
a shocking turn of events Natasha turns
out to be the VR form of Jane Fuller and
she doesn't recognize Douglas or
remember anything about the
multi-billion dollar Fuller Enterprise
however she admits that she feels a
strange connection with Douglas with
this Douglas finally unravels the
shocking truth that his world the 1997
Los Angeles is also another simulation
this is further confirmed when he drives
to a place where he would never have
considered going otherwise the end of
the world he discovers the Beyond a
point the world becomes a crude
wireframe model turns out that the
letter which Fuller had left for Douglas
was to explain that this world is also
not real meanwhile detective McBain
reaches Natasha's supermarket and
confronts her for lying about her
identity but as expected she neither
remembers him nor understands what he is
saying this makes McBain realize that
something is really wrong with this
world so he leaves to investigate
further panicking Natasha's real-life
user Jane Fuller downloads into her
again and contacts Douglas she asks to
meet him promising to reveal everything
shortly after when the two reunite Jane
gets straight to the point and explains
that there are thousands of simulations
but this is the only one that managed to
create a simulation within itself
exhibit must live here the real world is
actually in the year 2024 where she is
the daughter of Fuller she then reveals
that it was indeed Douglas who killed
the old man however she Comforts him
saying that it's not his fault because
he was being controlled by a user her
real-life husband David Jane reveals
that her husband was a decent man when
she first fell in love with him but his
time passed by something happened to him
he began to use the simulation as his
own personal playground where he killed
people for fun elsewhere at the VR lab
Jason gets curious about the simulation
so he downloads into Ashton's body
unfortunately he ends up getting killed
by a car inside the 1937 simulation
because of this Ashton's Consciousness
takes control of Jason's body in the 97
simulation the bartender is mesmerized
by the new environments and his strange
Behavior prompts the security to alert
Douglas who is in bed with Jane Douglas
quickly gets dressed and rushes to the
lab upon talking to Jason he figures out
that it's not his friend but instead the
Imposter bartender he tries to engage in
a normal conversation but Ashton holds
him at gunpoint and demands answers from
him left with no choice Douglas reveals
that they are not in the real world and
that they are both products of a VR
simulation saying this he takes Ashton
to the place where he was born the
computer lab although confused at first
Ashton starts liking the place and even
puts his gun down to breathe in the
fresh air suddenly Jane's husband David
from The Real World of 2024 takes
control of Douglas and kills Ashton
using his own gun he then finds his wife
at Douglas's apartment jealous he
attempts to murder her however before he
can do anything detective McBain arrives
at the scene and shoots him dead it
appears as if the detective has also
realized that they are in a simulation
before parting ways he requests Jane to
leave them alone once she goes back to
the real world the scene then cuts to
the real world it's the year 2024
David's death in 1997 simulation allows
Douglas's artificial simulation to take
over David's body in the real world what
he's shocked to wake up in a huge
mansion where he finally reunites with
Jane she takes him to the balcony to
show him the high-tech world of 2024
however the surprises don't end there as
Fuller turns out to be alive and well in
this real world the film ends with the
real world shrinking to a digital line
of imagery which may hint that this
world is also another simulation
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching